okay okay welcome everybody I would like
to thank the organizers for inviting me
to be here okay so yeah so this is
actually as you can see this Golden Gate
Bridge sorry rich yeah I know but it's
much more beautiful so there is actually
something similar in there's something
similar in Hong Kong if you come to I
psyche dis sumwhere you actually have to
cross this from from the airport so
that's that's what hey so uh yeah so the
topic of my talk is sorry that's the
most important message of my time
everything else is for free now ok so
whatever I would like to do is to
estimate the distribution histograms so
we've seen several talks related topics
today what I would like to talk about
using the pattern maximum likelihood
estimate to do that and especially fast
approximations to do that and I also
would like to talk about there is an
estimator bivalent and valiant and what
I would like to connect these two things
so fast approximation to the pml to this
may be invading and what we will see is
that there is a matrix that helps to
actually understand all these different
this different estimators so so that
will be kind of the key d the key
message so there is a dog list of
casting matrix that helps to explain all
the different estimators kind of that
helps you to access all these different
things ok so did the overview is like
this here so yeah the most important c
abbreviation is obviously pml pattern
maximum likelihood i will start by
defining what pml is then I will tell
you how you see it what is the point
yeah so this very week okay i will tell
you how you can express the pml
distribution in terms of the Gibbs free
energy then I will tell you about two
different approach
one of the beta approximation and others
think or approximation then I will tell
you about this valiant valiant
estimation and how you then connect
these different estimators and finally I
do some conclusions I think someone say
so we took it home there was a silence
that it was a Simon's pointer it's okay
so what's what's here an hour was an
hour ago it was still here okay so so
the setup is as follows what we have is
what we call this great memory source
that is described by a protégée
distribution we call it here pi and the
memory source produces iid samples on X
so yeah so what we assume is that pi is
unknown and we want to estimate it'll
actually you just want to have the
distribution histogram mouse we will see
later on is so so what we have is
available this n samples and based on
that we want to fight fine pi so pi is
distribution on one symbol and access i
ID'd wrong yes exactly that's the DS to
me so here to make an example so if you
have your alphabet ABCDEF then you have
like this would be kind of the sample
here huh you have here two four six
eight nine years symbols for example so
and of course we want to have a
typically we will have it longer huh
obviously you all know the ml estimator
of pi would be then you just you just
count come out into the CIA how often
did I see a B and so on and based on
that you take T of the ratios and
yesterday we were talking about ml
bashing so of course then the point one
or one of the points here is the demo
might not be the best you might want to
do especially in the regime where the
number of samples is on the order of the
alphabet size huh of course if the
number of samples here is way bigger
than your alphabet size and this is very
good but if it's this study the end here
the the sample size is on the order of
the alphabet size might not be
so here are things that you might care
about by extracting from the
distribution one of dem st s is the
entropy and the other is to support site
so there's just plugging that estimator
sir but as we have seen is it might not
be the best thing you actually want to
do okay so this is actually just like
your distribution or own just to
graphically represent and for many
purposes it turns out it's sufficient to
actually have a sorted distribution of
the kind of the all which is then
essentially amounts to having the
distribution histogram you just care
about how many symbols have probability
0.35 how many symbols has probability
0.2 and and so on that's equivalent to
having just a sorted so here I'm doing
sorting you of course I doubt if I don't
know the distribution I don't don't know
this sort in any way and well the
important thing is that if you're trying
to estimate the entropy or if you're
interested to estimate the support you
don't really need pie it's enough to
have to sort it a version or the
distribution into is to grow out of the
point here and what you observe is when
you when you try actually to estimate P
it's sufficient not to look at X it
sufficient look at what is known as the
pattern huh so the bodies to pattern
well if you have like something like
here you observed a sequence then the
pattern that you associate with that is
nothing else than the first observed
symbol your associate number one so here
C becomes one then we here we see see
again so year everyone again then the
next symbol the distinct next distinct
symbol we observe is a so we give it
number two then this is again this thing
so we get three but see we have seen it
before so we gave it in a same label we
have given it before so one and so this
is the pattern of off of this sequence
and we turns out of details either
obviously it's not too difficult to see
that is actually a sufficient statistic
if you're trying to find the sorted
distribution or the distribution is
so the setup that we have here is a
century this year here we had p here we
have the sorted version here we have
kind of two here and then obviously when
we you know to getting the pattern which
symbol gets number one which number to
doing it again some permutation here
again this is unknown is this this
permutation at this distribution that is
permutation of course also unknown of
course you can combine these dissolute
just two permutations here the the
concatenation of two permutation is just
one big permutation so that's kind of
the key key object here we have a
permutation here from one to six and
here also to 126 and you can describe a
permutation in terms of a permutation
matrix permutation matrix it's just a
square matrix or all the columns and
throw some 21 and also all the entries
are 0 and 1 that's a permutation right
so the sequence the second permutation
is a random permutation that's being
based on your observation yeah but you
don't know it because pi is not known
yeah anyway they did yeah so this is a
permutation matrix here just you can
describe it'll be the permutation or
permutation matrix its equivalent okay
so so what are all its and his coworker
said yeah when we want to yeah so
obviously if you want to estimate the P
we should just look at the pattern
that's a sufficient statistics that we
have seen and so yeah they define the
pattern maximal active distribution
nothing else than to be p the one that
maximizes p given sigh given that you
have p let's see of the obvious
definition of this pml distribution and
if you do the math since she's just been
riding out what this really means here
and you see you have just to go over all
possible permutations that's where here
the whole thing comes you just go over
all possible permutations that can
happen and when you ride out really the
details then you get this
here sir yeah yeah I've got the cookies
though you go back to the day the fee
here in the side side pattern well how
why do you associate a pattern with the
permutation because this is a pattern
more than that it tells you like how
many times water peers and how many
times you appear yeah no it's just a
pair the permutation is what I don't
know is like here a so see a PS the
first so I associate one here ba appears
a second a second so is 2d appears the
third so I become three the fact is he
appears three times so that doesn't
appear here but that's information right
yeah alright so this is not catching
order to make sure the public oh no no
yeah this is not this is tricky does it
not sigh here this is just the alphabet
in what size expressed the so this is
the X you know this is an X vector that
is the alphabet of X this is the
alphabet of sir SOSUS I will just be a
string of numbers one to answer and so
this is also just these are all
alphabets and just permuting the
alphabets
so when you do the math you just since
you just go over all possible permit not
gonna be working so this is just of
overall permutations huh you do all
possible permutations and it turns out
that this is nothing else than a
so-called permanent if you right here
matrix is this nice form here very
general entries pi/2 the MU J then it
turns out that this expression up here
is just to permanent permanent is very
similar likely determinant but when
you'd only determinant you have some
terms or pluses and some terms of
minuses in the permanent is everything
is just pluses now the definition is
simpler but when you want to compute
it's actually a more complicated it's
actually much more complicated and
actually here comes the third valiant
into the game so the father of the two
variants he worked on that let's leyland
and he showed like how complex disease
actually huh so yeah so we know that
have two regions of the third one and so
the question is how can you approximate
these things so it's not going to be
tractable obviously computing this here
is difficult to even optimizing it might
be even difficult what we're having is
really think of it we have a class of
matrices now what we need to find is
really the P that maximizes the
permanent of this matrix in a restricted
set of matrices we want to find the one
is the maximal permanent so in general
what you have is the problem we have a
class of matrices parameterize by P we
can plot I mean this will be high
dimension saying we can plot the
permanent for each of these matrices and
we want to find the maximum that's kind
of ideally what you want to do now as I
said this is intractable and so you're
wondering how can what can you do there
are different approaches to do that one
of them is to use sample Markov chain
Monte Carlo approaches to kind of
estimate the permanent that's one
approach and another approach is to do
surrogate functions so so this would be
kind of the ideal function that you want
to maximize but that's difficult to
maximize so let's do an approximation a
surrogate function
that DD idea is obviously okay it will
be different but it's easy to maximize
that's kind of the approach you want to
do here we want to do the surrogate
approach and what will the approach
we're looking is a debate approximation
or distinct or approximation I'll say a
bit more after that but just to give you
kind of some numerics what I did is just
for ten by ten matrices I mean these
matrices in practice are much bigger
there will be thousand by thousands but
to do the numerix into computer correct
permanent I just restricted myself to
ten by ten Matri season so what I did I
did I sampled 10,000 matrices and a
computer to the exact permanent and I
can compute these arrogant functions and
what I did I plotted for every of these
samples I plotted a point here is a true
permanent or so the x-axis is it true
permanent or he logarithm and here i
have the vertical axis is than the DD
circuit would and we have here blue blue
estimate kind of you get lower bounds
here this is the sinkhole what i call
the sink pork exclamation and the red
one is the beta approximation so you see
here the from numerically the
synchronous image is much much closer to
the true value here this is would be
this would be kind of 2 45 degree line
so to speak but what you see is that the
red line actually much nicely much more
nicely a match is this loop and when you
want to optimize something it's actually
much more important that you match the
slope not that you match the actual
actual value and tell you what you
actually owe then also observe is that
when you do really numerix debate
approximation gives to them better
approximation of the pml than the
sinkhole okay just so kind of general
information so what you have what since
you can prove this thing corn
approximation so this essentially I gave
this name to this approximation anyway
this has worked on linear summary need
skin victors and then they show that you
get a etudie an approximation let's go
very good yeah but it's much but you see
I mean you can actually do it let me
comment on that after so the interesting
thing for the beta approximation you can
actually get this was proven last year
you can do well 2 to the N approximation
is connected to be a square root 2 to
the N approximation so this is actually
the best deterministic polynomial time
algorithm known to date to approximate
the permanent of course you can be much
better if you have a stochastic
algorithms but for deterministic
algorithms this turns out to be
currently the best known and what you
speak you what you see is obviously
things much much better than then what
these guarantees also one of my efforts
is to currently better understand what's
why you actually get much better than
these naive bounce or anyway so how does
this whole thing work we do this this a
beta approximate just to give you kind
of a high-level overview of things so so
that's the problem we are looking at we
want to find we have a class class of
matrices parameterize by p and we want
to find a matrix that maximizes the
permanent now that the idea and the
trick after all these things is to
actually make things more complicated in
a first step namely we replace this by
another maximization problem kind of a
variational characterization of this
permanent that's what we do this guy
here is called a free energy from
statistical mechanics the details are
not terribly important but the key thing
is that you can express this this scalar
value no value of an optimization
problem and then you plug it in and you
get a double of optimization problem and
what you can obviously tell me perhaps
what you can then obviously do is you
can let me see you can alternate time
between the two you can alternate
between P and gamma and and so on and
then find TD often let me come back to
this so there are different ways to
actually uh parameterize what turns out
to be one suitable approximation to so
suitable way to do is this matrix gamma
which is a doubly stochastic matrix and
it's actually nothing else than the
matrix that you
have here that you would get by kind of
disease is nothing else than the a
posteriori probability Iraqi this is the
postural probability overall the Sigma's
times or possible permutation matrices
so that's kind of the rules so this is
kind of the key key object actually that
relates all these these algorithms it's
really like this this double stochastic
matrix that you have here that is
obtained by averaging over all
permutation matrices and waited by the a
posteriori probability and what you do
is essentially you very this gamma you
don't think this it's just that the
optimum is this expression and the trick
is really to vary this gamma and they
really have the optimum you get the
correct value maximization and now the
approximations the idea is nothing else
well this is in general a complicated
function so it's not practical either
there are too many parameters or it's a
complicated x too complicated expression
so what you do is your approximate is
this function here here it's always a
nice convex function but it's not
tractable so what you do is your
approximated by other free energy
functions in general action is beta
finishing is not sooner not too nice but
I was able to a couple years ago was
able to show that actually in this case
it's a very nice function it's nicely
convex so it's actually very nicely
behaved click on getting dumber
no this is for a good question this is
forgiven tetas it's its convex yeah and
vice versa but not in bhosle nothing
both obviously and you get 10 L again
you can do the same thing you fix p
optimized gamma you fix gamma you
optimize p and so you get a alternating
maximization algorithm and this step
here d this you can do with a graphical
model you can run the sub product
algorithm and i also shown you a couple
have shown a couple years ago that it
nicely converges in general some product
alchemy does not need to converge but
for this graphical model you can show
you nicely converges and think corn is
that kind of the same idea it's yet
another approximation instead of this
Gibbs free energy function you take what
I call to sing corner free energy
function it's actually kind of some
relative entropy type of expression and
then on a high level is exactly the same
thing here the why I call this the same
corner approximation is because this is
given by a sink horn scaling of a matrix
when you have a matrix and you scale all
the columns and then scale all the rows
alternating that is nothing else as a
sinkhole algorithm and so that's why I
call it the sinkhole algorithm because
if you want to solve that that is as I
said you use the sinkhole a proximal
guri okay so what is now the this was
now pml stuff and efficient
approximation is off of that pml
business now what is this valiant valent
stuff they're trying to estimate the
same thing they also trying to find the
distribution histogram and the trick
that they used to make progress on the
topic was they use the personalization
trick so instead of sequences of length
n like what I looked at they looked at
sequences of length and primer and
primer paso with parameter N and the
good thing is that the multiplicities of
this pattern symbols already independent
if you fix and they're dependent because
they have to some 2n huh but when you
have n prime to be paso then the
multiplicities our independence sings or
than
to analyze obviously you afterwards you
need to get rid again of this
personalization yeah so you see all the
Mews here the probability that you
observe symbol meet x is given x plus so
n times the probability of the simple so
so the way they make progress on this is
then they set up a linear program this
is just a simplified version of it they
have depending if there are symbols that
appear frequently or not they have
different versions here is just kind of
a simplified version to give you kind of
the flavor what they did is they they
set up P vector here they have here some
P that appears k 1 times the P that
appears k 2 times and the P that appears
KL x so so the peas are actually chosen
from some alphabet they don't allow all
the peace they just allow certain
alphabet and then essentially what boils
down to find the histogram is not
finding the peace but finding k1 finding
came to finding KO that's what it boils
down to is kind of a nice reformulation
of the whole thing essentially when you
look at the paper the bigger q is be the
bigger the set of the piece that you
allow the easier is to beef guarantees
but of course you don't want it too big
because then the optimization problem
comes to too large so the trick is to
choose this just big enough so that you
have nice properties yet not too big
enough though so that it's tractable
yeah so what it turns out actually what
they implicitly do they implicitly also
you can then derive when you have found
this piece door you seem to empirically
also have essentially gamma matrix
behind him this doubly stochastic
matrices that appeared in this gibbs
free energy formulation than this beta
finished formulations in confirming
energy formulation implicitly what they
do they also estimate the gamma matrix
that is given by this expression so here
we have the piece we have muta
multiplicities here Phi this is the
prevalence this is how often do you see
a symbol with a given multiplicity so
you can show you cannot make exact
statements but you can say that this is
actually approximately doubly stochastic
for a finite k and then and you can
actually show that it is close to be a
stationary point of the sinkhole free
energy function so so it's very close
you can kind of think of it as an
approximation to the thing corn free
energy function in his elation problem
here yeah as I say it's approximately I
think you can if you let n to infinity
and so on you could kind of say you know
these conversions to that but you know
we're mostly interested in finite length
short scene so possibly you could give
bounce island look too much into that ok
so the conclusions of my talk is the
following so what I've shown you I've
define you the pattern maximum
likelihood estimate on the other hand I
have shown you this railing Valley an
estimate of she's just very very briefly
tell you what it is I've shown you
connection so that the main object is
really disturbing stochastic matrix and
it this is given by you know when I had
this graphical representation we have
this permanent permutation matrices and
when you average over all possible
permutations when and with a given
weight then you get a cinch this this
this doubly stochastic matrix so this is
a key object is this matrix gamma that
connects all these various
approximations and obviously yeah once
you have seen the valiant valiant stuff
you can also then think of how can
actually speed up my bait approximation
to the PM LS income approximation to the
pml it's also one thing i'm looking at
currently so thank you very much so is
their theory you think that it's
actually complexity aside you could get
the PA round at a good thing if it's
good thing or not I mean well along she
don't show your nice properties of the
pml so yeah I mean scale of the problem
sorry